marc bienvenida un poco a postergar
nuestras secciones de salud por esta
barrera prensa que estábamos esperando
del presidente pueblo de mir selenski y
el presidente macro no pues empecemos
con nuestra sección mar hoy empezamos
con una buena noticia a raúl y es que
son tres personas que eran parapléjicas
es decir que no tenían movilidad en sus
extremidades inferiores ni en el tronco
pudieron volver a caminar pudieron
volver a andar gracias a una nueva
terapia desarrollada por varios
institutos de la salud de la universidad
de los daneses significa como ven en
estas imágenes por ejemplo que hay
nuevas personas que pueden ir andando a
ver a tomar unas cervezas con sus amigos
después de años sin poder ni siquiera
dar un solo paso esta terapia
experimental consiste en implantar unos
electrodos que quirúrgicamente lo hacen
que envían unas señales eléctricas en
toda la médula espinal y estas señales
imitan las señales nerviosas que manda
el cerebro a las extremidades inferiores
en este caso y al tronco y luego con un
sistema de inteligencia se controlan
estos estímulos eléctricos implantados
en la médula espinal y se reproducen
estas las señales que ordenan caminar o
reproducir otro tipo de acciones físicas
no es la primera vez que sucede algo así
en eeuu ya han habido algunos casos y
este mismo equipo suizo lo logró también
en 2018 con este con otro paciente pero
en esta vez este caso lo que lo
diferencia es que ha sido un progreso
increíblemente rápido sólo en un día ya
podían moverse personas que tenían
además pues la médula espinal totalmente
lesionada esto ha sido gracias a una
mejora tecnológica que se ha
desarrollado también en los últimos
meses y esto es lo que explicaban los
expertos
es una tecnología mucho más precisa que
nos permite dirigirnos a individuos con
las formas más severas de lesiones
medulares sesiones clínicas completas
sin sensaciones sin movimiento sesión
números mange y moldes de spa no hicimos
un modelo de la médula espinal para
entender exactamente la anatomía de
estos lugares y luego diseñamos la
estimulación siguiendo la anatomía de
cada persona
es un programa de simulación muy
personalizado
el hecho de que sea tan personalizado
sin embargo el aumento agua un poco la
fiesta hace que sea también mucho más
difícil hacer este tratamiento a gran
escala entonces veremos cómo se combinan
estos dos factores para que las lesiones
de médula dejen de ser un daño
irreversible
marc y pues ya todos estamos
familiarizados con las variantes debido
a esta pandemia x 19 pero hablemos de
una variante no necesariamente de este
virus unido del otro hablo del vih que
sabemos de ese nuevo hallazgo para
preocuparse pues no tanto la verdad es
que todos nos hemos convertido en
expertos de virología e inmunología
últimamente y es que en países bajos se
ha encontrado una nueva variante del
virus de inmunodeficiencia humana
probablemente circula además desde hace
años eso por eso probablemente nos
debemos preocupar tanto repasemos las
cifras de por qué dicen que es más
virulento no por un lado hace que las
personas infectadas tengan una carga
viral entre 35 y 55 veces más alta que
en los casos de las variantes de la
variante que ya se era conocida y además
se multiplica por dos la rapidez en la
que se daña el sistema inmune que es una
de las principales
consecuencias del vih sin embargo estas
mutaciones no hacen que el virus sea
resistente a los tratamientos tanto
posteriores como de prevención que
existen para evitar el sida eso
significa dos cosas una que estas
mutaciones no han ocurrido como una
resistencia a los tratamientos es una
buena noticia y la otra es que es más
importante que nunca que las personas
accedan a los tratamientos lo más rápido
posible porque al no ser resistente a
los medicamentos pues estos fármacos si
son capaces de cortar la transmisión y
se pueden neutralizar así está esta
nueva virulencia que dicen que tiene
esta variante mari también pues al
entrar a un sexo seguro y pues ante la
duda mejor pues de recurrir al médico
para tener un diagnóstico temprano
porque recordemos que es una enfermedad
con la que se puede vivir pues avanza un
nuevo tratamiento antiviral contra el
cob y 19 si volvemos con nuestro coach
volvemos a nuestro tema favorito parece
se trata un antiviral japonés en este
caso de la farmacia o de la farmacéutica
perdón shionogi es un antiviral parecido
a los de merck
desarrollado por facer y quieren
aprobarlo lo antes posible esto es lo
que decía el primer ministro
escuchémoslo
aunque si tuviera 2 ukic para
comercializar este fármaco ahora lo
antes posible si los ensayos clínicos
muestran que es seguro y efectivo lo
revisaremos rápidamente y consideraremos
usar todos los métodos posibles incluye
la aprobación condicional
además de apoyar la investigación y el
desarrollo
también estamos dando subsidios para los
costos de los ensayos clínicos para
acelerar la comercialización existe
youtube gurú diario
se cree que de hecho podría hasta llegar
en este mes la aprobación provisional de
este fármaco sin embargo todavía faltan
los estudios de fase 3 por ahora parece
que el medicamento tiene un buen efecto
en los casos de ccoo bit moderado reduce
los síntomas también reduce la carga
viral más rápido en los pacientes que lo
tomaron que los pacientes que tomaron un
placebo pero indudablemente hace falta
tener más datos sin embargo la
diversidad de tratamientos que no queden
unas pocas manos siempre va a ser una
buena noticia más rápidamente para
terminar datos sobre el personal de
enfermería en españa después de la
pandemia creo que estamos hablando de
salud mental estamos hablando de varias
cosas una de ellas de salud mental
repasemos entonces rápidamente los datos
que han surgido en estos últimos días y
es que casi la mitad de los
profesionales de enfermería de españa
después de la pandemia quiso dejar su
trabajo y además un tercio de ellos del
33 por ciento tuvo depresión y también
la mitad se contagio de kobe 19 son
datos que alarman un poco pues de las
condiciones de trabajo de este personal
de enfermería en el caso español y que
además pues tiene mucho que ver también
con la precariedad que sufren en españa
sólo hay cinco o seis profesionales de
la salud por cada 100.000 habitantes
como vemos aquí esto es una cifra que
está la cola de europa y además el 92
por ciento de sus contratos en los
hospitales tanto públicos como privados
son temporarios raúl lamenta doble mar
espero que esto cambio porque ya nos
dimos cuenta pues de lo importante que
son estas personas en nuestra vida